Noël Bram bonjour bonjour Véronique
merci d'être avec nous dans une serre du
Trianon nous sommes à versaill bien sûr
et nous vous avons invité dans cette
serre pour parler de votre émission
enfin de vous bien sûr et entre autres
de cette émission qui s'appelle Silence
ça pousse que vous coprésentez avec
Stéphane Marie depuis combien de temps
déjà oh une douzaine d'années silence à
pousse en fait Stéphane Marie prépare
faisait déjà sur France 5 une émission
d'un quart d'heure je crois à peu près
on voyait que ses mains et donnit des
conseils de jardinage et puis Fran lui a
demandé de faire une émission plus
longue h HM donc avec une vraie
présentation un présentateur dont on ne
verra pas que les mains mais la tête les
pieds tout ce qu'on veut et il a cherché
ou françin lui a proposé de de se s'
coquiner avec une présentatrice pour
qu'il soit deux pour que ce soit plus
vivant et donc c'est Franin qui nous a
marié d'accord je crois qu'on lui a
proposé plusieurs filles il est très
discret
là-dessus vous aussi et et finalement
nous on s'est bien entenduêt voilà on
s'est bien entendu oui en fait faut pas
que je m'en orgueillise trop parce qu'
en fait il m'a choisi parce qu'il savait
que j'allais lui la paix ah
d'accord ouais pas pour un talent
extraordinaire mais parce qu'il s'est
dit celle-ci elle pas embêtante
ouis voilà et il avait raison parce que
je pense que je lui fous la pai oui mais
bon tout tout fonctionne bien tout va
bien c'est un c'est un vrai change je
l'admire c'est agréable de travailler
ouais mais sincèrement je l'admire et
travailler avec quelqu'un qu'on admire
c'est bien vous savez travailler avec
quelqu'un qu'on admire pas c'est pénible
oui je t'imagine sont tous à la longueur
oui ou oui alors comment est-ce que vous
vous répartissez les rôles avec Stéphane
Marie il y a a plusieurs parties dans
votre émission il y a plusieurs parties
c'est Stéphane Marie le chef c'est son
émission c'est lui le grand chef il fait
des reportages il fait ce qu'on appelle
des pas de PANI qui va dans des jardins
pour les les refaire ou en tout cas
refaire une partie ou
solutionner un problème des gens qui
appellent au secours des gens qui
appellent au secours qui sont parfois
des très bons jardiniers mais ils se
disent bon bah là j'ai un petit coin
d'OM il y a rien qui pousse ou j'ai un
poteau ou j'ai un visavis bon voilà et
Stéphane est très très fort là-dedans il
a vraiment le sens de de l'espace des
couleurs et puis il connaît vraiment
plein de plantes et puis de plus en plus
parce que passé weekend dans les
jardineries il adore ça donc il a
toujours des bonnes idées une baguette
magique des solution bagette magique et
puis un bon savoir voilà et moi je alors
votre rôle à vous moi je fais ce qu'on
appelle dans notre jargon les plateaux
c'est-à-dire quand on est tous les deux
entre les reportages Stéphane donne des
conseils et en fait il me parle à moi
qui suis profane et il m'explique comme
ça se permet peut-être d'être plus
vivant d'être plus clair d'être plus
c'est plus facile de parler à quelqu'un
que de parler comme ça oui d'accordam
comme oua et et puis on s'entend bien et
puis on fait des trucs un peu un peu
marrant oui il y a un esprit assez
joyeux assez vivant et et vous êtes
vraiment profane si profane que ça bah
depuis depu comm par rentrer
j'imagine vous des raisons vque ça finit
par rentrer j'ai appris un tas de trucs
mais c'est toujours pareil plus on sait
et plus on sait qu'on sait pas ce que je
veux dire c'est immense c'est immense
voilà très bien et alors moi j'aimerais
en savoir un peu plus sur vous donc vous
êtes yvelinoise évidemment oui j'abite
près de Versailles voilà vous êtes
souvent dans le parc vous promenez voilà
maintenant vous vous découvrez les ser
ça c'est fait qu' vous connaissez pas
voilà et sinon comment vous êtes arrivé
à cette carrière journalistique à la
télévision à la radio comment ça s'est
passé radio j'ai commencé par Laadi j'ai
tout tout tout début j'ai commencé à
énergie je resté à peu près 6 mois c
mais les tout début des radiololad
c'était complètement artisanal c'était
sympa et puis après je suis allée sur
Europe 1 ils m'ont engagé il m'ont viré
aussi sec et après je suis allé sur
France interre et là j'étais bien
c'était la place la bonne place c'était
la bonne place et j'y suis toujours
c'est j'adore cet endroit j'adore
travailler là-bas c'est et alors vous
avez fait plusieurs émissions j'imagine
là-bas depuis C j'ai tout fait j'ai fait
la nuit le matin l'après-midi heureux le
matin heure l'aprèsmidi non je suis
arrivée après l'oreay en coin j'ai
jamais fait quoi vous savez quoi mais
vraiment n'importe quoi sur Internet
parce que j'ai j'ai vu l'oreille en coin
j'ai vu que vous aviez fait des études
de sciences et en fait pas du tout j'ai
jamais fait d'études de sciences et j'ai
jamais fait l'oreille en coin mais je
suis bien sur France Inter et j'aime et
voilà VO voilà on va parler un peu plus
de plantes oh voilà c'est l'occasion on
va appeler Monsieur Christian bojot qui
est l'adjoint jeir Chris bonjour on vous
appelle qui est l'adjoint d'Alain
Baraton bonjour bonjour et qui est aussi
je vous présente nolam enchanté voilà
bour et qui est aussi responsable des
ces tout à fait comment marathon dans le
boulot très bien
ah ou marathon c'est un de vos collègues
aussi un collègue de radio ouais c'est
un copain alors là nous sommes dans la
serre des plantes vertes tout à fait oui
pourquoi parce que c'est une ser c'est
la seule serre que parce que les plantes
sont
encore ser jolie avec des chos
alorsjourd'hui voilà et puis c'est c'est
les seules plantes qu'on garde encore
abrité sous sous les
on peuter voilà qui sont relativement
fragiles ah mais c'est hyper intéressant
ça veut dire que vous avez d'autres
serres par exemple en été que toutes les
plantes qu'on voit là au Triano c'est
vous qui les avez faitous voilà elles
part d'ici is soit de semi soit de
bouture mais tout part d'ici vous êtes
aussi non seulement il y a non seulement
des jardins mais des usines à fleurs ici
voilà c'est un peu le la
nurcerie oui nurcerie c'est plus joli
couponnière neurseris crè che jardin
d'f et un peu hôpital aussi parce que
lorsque les plantes sont distribuées à
droite à gauche quand elles reviennent
ici bon elles ont besoin d'être ou
rampoté ou chouchouté d'accord parce que
là on a des plantes vertes qui ne sont
pas destinés à être dehors mais à être
dedans voilà dans les bureaux dans les
dans les salles de réception et voilà
qu' sort pctuellement selon les besoins
voilà et puis elles ont un autre rôle
vous nous disiez on est un peu dans une
serre une serre école si on peut
dire on reçoit beaucoup d'apprentis et
de stagiaires donc voilà qui apprenent
le métier de jardinier donc ces
planteslà servent à leur montrer comment
on bouture les plantes comment on les
multiplie donc soit par semi soit par
bouture de feuilles soit par bouture de
de tronçon de tige ou voilà donc ça
permet aux apprentis de voir un petit
peu dans l'APSE de temps où ils sont là
de faire une bouture et de la voir
grandir ou pas voilà donc de savoir
pourquoi il l' louper pourquoi
contrairement à l'école où là on peut
être à côté d'eux vraiment leur montrer
parce on a un apprentis des fois deux on
ils sont pas 15 ou 20 comme dans les les
classes malheureusement donc ce qui fait
que c'est plus plus facile de leur
expliquer ça leur permet eux de de poser
plus de questions et de puis voir le le
le résultat de leur travailune petite
pousse comme ça et on arrive à faire un
arbre qui fait 1,50 2 m de haut selon
l'espèce là on a des des arbres qui ont
démarré pouss chez vous la plupart de ce
qu'il y a ici sont été bouturés depuis
on va dire 2000 dans les années 2000
c'est grisant ça vous V certains ont une
dizaines d'années d'autres un peu moins
parce que c'est fait par semi donc elles
sont elles ont quoi un an ou deux et les
autres toutes les grandes ont en moyenne
depuis ou voz 4 5 ans quoi les celles
qui sont ici c'est les plus grosses sont
dans la galerie celles-ci sont date de
2000 là on est encore dans la nurerie
avec les les jeunes et les ados et les
bébés on les voit les bébés regardez
montrez-nous un bébé Noël ben ça c'est
vraiment vraiment sympa regardez là il y
a le le papa c'est c'est celui-ci d'
c'est celui-ci qui a été tiré voilà mag
les boutur la maman les bébé et ça donne
les bébés voilà voà
voà c'est de celle c'est de celle-ci que
l'on fait dans dans toutes C voilà à
partir de celle-là vous avez fait celle
là vous avez fait ça puis toutes les
petites qu'on a encore dans le do la
plart de de tout ce qui est ici sont
sont faites comme ça voilà c'est génial
he c'est plus ou Mo comment ça s'ppelle
c'est un fitonia comment un fitonia
phitonia ou là attention c'est danse he
c'est extrêmement danse on a envie de
s'assoir dessus ça sert de tabourette
c'est une plante traçante donc voilà
donc là vous la laissez toucher la terre
elle va s'enraciner elle va continuer
c'est comme le lière elle reste au rat
du
sol non monte pas très trèsut
CCI elle envahit même non c'est une
l'ombre mais beaucoup de lumière
pas le soleil vif donc c'est ce qui fait
que plus le elles sont à l'ombre plus le
le feuillage reste
foncé c'est bien bien marqué celle-ci
était un peu trop au soleil voyez elle
souffre un petit peu oui elle a blanchi
ah c'est intéressant c'est hyper inint
moi j'adore ça c'est hyper intéressant
c'est donc si on la veut il faut le
savoir parce que si en fait si vous
voulez plante claire vous la mettez au
soleil ouais beaucoup c'est ça que vous
vouliez dire Nol ouais merci mais je
vous en prie et si voulez une plante
francée à l'ombre c'est le contraire des
humains
oui la lumière est bien pour nous bon
ben génial donc la serre des plantes
vertes il existe la serre des légumes la
serre de légumes donc ici on a une serre
chaude c'est là où on fait tous les
semis donc légumes fleurs tout voilà
donc c'est une serre qui est énormément
chauffée donc c'est le même style que
celle-ci mais il y a beaucoup plus de
chauffage dedans et donc elle est
chauffer beaucoup plus que les autres ah
c'est pour ça qu'il fait bon voilà là
vous avez 18 20°gr là bon avec le soleil
un peu plus mais en principe la nuit il
a 18 20°gr voilà ok donc sert des
légumes sert des fleurs sert des fleurs
voilà après les légumes sont repliés
dans les jardins potagers où là ils
grossissent et il vont là où ils sont
destinés on un grand restaurant le
restaurant de Monsieur indicace voilà
tout à fait et en plus on décore le le
hameau de marieanttoinette où là on
prend aussi des légumes pour le
restaurant de Monsieur Ducas et le reste
sert à décorer le le Hau comme à
l'époque de marieanttoinette c'est
classe hein très class voà donc c'est et
c'est des légumes sain puisqu'on ne
traite plus
voilà d'ù
l'avantage voilà donc ce petit caret
bleu là il sert tout simplement à gérer
la population d'insectes néfastes aux
plantes vertes d'accord donc ils
viennent se coller sur parce que c'est
collant donc il vient se coller dessus
on compte à peu près on fait des des
petits carrés on compte combien il y a
d'insectes sur chaque carré et ça nous
indique s'il faut qu'on fasse un Larché
d'insectes prédateur pour manger les les
petites bêtes qui sont et après les
insectes prédateurs on les reTue avec
d'autres insectes non les insectes
prédateurs se finissent par disparaître
au bout du moment où il y a plus rien à
manger pour eux ah on les laisse ils aut
détruits euxmêmes quoi voilà extrêement
agréable c'est pour ça je dire qu'il
faut qu'on gère la population avec ça
par j'ai l'impression il y a pas grand
chose'est-ce que vous en PZ conna c'est
pas il y a pas trop il juste ce qu'il
faut ou très bien ben écoutez un grand
merci et ben de rien on va essayer de
faire un petit tour de serre pour
admirer toutes ces jolies plantesentendu
et puis euh j'ai envie de vous dire je
sais pas quand est-ce qu'il faut revenir
au printemps printemps c'est plus joli
comme ça on voit déjà les semis on voit
les graines qui gè et voilà et après fin
mars début avril où là où les ses sont
vraiment pleines les plantes sont en
peau elles commence à fleurir elles sont
prêtes à partir sur les plantations donc
c'estter ça sur notre calpin super merci
je suis ravie d'avoir vu CHR merci
chrtian plaisir mercion ben merci Noël
d'être venu voyez et ben grâce à vous
grâce à vous ben non grâce à vous avec
tous vos centres d'intérêt on découvre
plein de choses à bientôt au revoir au
revoir